a TV series that spawned eight nine
years is incredibly difficult thing to
end I think not everyone's gonna be
happy you know and you can't please
everyone
everybody is Charlie there's been a
whole bunch of Lannister related news
between Tyrion Jaime and Kit Harington
even did an interview talking about the
final season Peter Dinklage also dropped
a huge bomb about that Tyrion scene at
the end of season seven when they were
on the sex boat there were so many
debates about what was going on on his
face here and what this meant but he
actually clarified so we get a break it
all down if you're brand new to the
channel we're doing a new round to that
4k blu-ray giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video this is Peter
Dinklage's interpretation of this scene
he was doing this during an interview
with Entertainment Weekly recently where
he said it's complicated a lot of the
time with Tyrion it's professional and
personal obviously he has feelings for
Daenerys he loves her or he thinks he
does she's inspiring and he's
questioning that inside himself because
he doesn't have a good track record of
falling in love we're still wondering
where his first wife went so he goes on
to say there's jealousy wrapped up in
there when the episode actually aired
this is the clip that they released with
him talking about it and it's completely
different from what he said recently
it's dangerous for everybody involved
I'm sure it's good for both of them in
the moment but you don't even get the
relief of how beautiful it could be or
should be it's no it's just it's not
good but it should be but it's not it's
Game of Thrones it's a long history of
romance not ending well on this show so
originally I think after watching both
the finale and then that clip that they
released with the finale most people
were on board with the idea that Tyrion
wasn't so much sexually upset about this
situation like I want it to be with
Daenerys and now Jon Snow is with her he
was more upset about him usurping his
influence with Daenerys because she was
starting to listen to him more starting
to take more chances with her dragons in
order to save him like when she got word
that Jon Snow was trapped north of the
wall and she immediately wanted to take
off tyrion cautioned her not to go so
this new interview just completely drops
a bomb on all that like he actually
really does
like he wants to be with Daenerys and
maybe they'll use that for some drama
during season eight I hope that they
don't spend too much time on that
because that's the least interesting
kind of love triangle drama like Tyrion
was never meant to be with Daenerys in
that way like we've all talked about the
DVD commentary where one of the
directors was saying that George R
Martin walking around on season one set
was saying oh yeah you know all this
stuff this is really important but it's
really about getting Jon Snow and
Daenerys together and that was way back
during season one so unless you're
really deep into your fanfiction it
wasn't like we really expected Tyrion to
be with Daenerys in a biblical sense let
me know in the comments what you
actually think about Peter Dinklage's
comments about that and how that's going
to influence what they do at least in
the first part of season 8 because
obviously most of its going to be
dedicated to wrapping up all these
character arcs separately a lot of
people were wondering about an interview
that the visual effects team we're doing
that mentioned Tyrion so here's a clip
of that and then we go holy how are
we gonna do this and then we all sit
around and figure out a plan of attack
that involves us if it cannot be
photographed if it cannot be
photographed visual effects will figure
out a way to add the scope and add the
Wiz and the bang and we can't tell you
and what episode Tyrion dies the funny
thing about that is that Tyrion has
always been on my survivors list like of
all the people that you think are gonna
die obviously it's a very long list
Tyrion is not on it because he's that
unlikely hero the way George RR martin
has envisioned the character the way
he's written to be is the most clever of
all the characters so if anyone is gonna
survive it's gonna be Tyrion but the
funny thing is is that recently we
learned because Nikolaj coster-waldau is
having a lawsuit with one of his old
managers it was revealed that he stars
in all six episodes of season 8 remember
there's only six episodes in the final
season so all the Lannisters survived
till episode 6 which I don't think
should come as too much of a shock I
don't even consider it spoilery maybe
back in season 4 season 5 when we were
trying to guess how these characters
would end up it was always possible that
people could die before the finale but
with the way they've structured the last
couple of seasons in the way the TV show
has become more like traditional Network
TV in that they
have a bunch of really good actors so
they want to feature them as much as
possible regardless of what their story
is so they put a bunch of plot armor on
them so that's how you wind up with all
of the Lannisters surviving til episode
six kid Harrington also did an interview
recently talking about the final season
saying that he feels like the finale is
definitely gonna disappoint some people
so here's that clip curious about like
expectations going into this final
season I mean do you feel like what you
guys have shot can possibly live up to
the imagination in the mind of the fans
of this show I hope so I think a TV
series that spans eight nine years is
incredibly difficult thing to end I
think not everyone's gonna be happy you
know and you can't please everyone my
favorite TV shows a Sopranos and
Breaking Bad and the war and they all
ended in a way that I you know the econ
is not it's never gonna satisfy you you
think this ends in a diner with you guys
were sitting in a diner oh yeah yeah
I've already done a couple videos about
how I think that Jaime and Cersei are
going to wind up because I definitely
think that they are going to die
but of all the people that are gonna be
left to rule in the ashes and help
rebuild the kingdom Tyrion has always
been at the top of my list you know
likely outcomes is that he's left alive
to raise Jon Snow and Daenerys his baby
if they both wind up dying
so Daenerys would have to survive long
enough to at least give birth to that
and even though we don't know exactly
how much time is going to pass between
the beginning of season 8 and the end of
season 8 if there's gonna be like some
giant time jump in that last episode
where you have a Lord of the Rings
Return of the King style montage where
usually this is what happens to all the
characters is you have groups of people
the hobbits sail off to the Grey Havens
but because of what Kidd Harrington said
I'm not totally expecting that and that
is a very conventional way to end things
and Game of Thrones has always prided
itself on turning conventions on their
heads so I'm not expecting a Sopranos
cut to black WTF moment where they just
give us all the middle finger and you
don't get any definitive ending
I think they'll definitely be an ending
like you'll know exactly who's going to
be left alive to survive and try to
rebuild the kingdom but there been a lot
of people associated with the show that
have sort of thrown in their theories
about how it's going to end like the
after that used to play Loras that's
playing iron fist now he actually said
that he thinks that there's not going to
be an Iron Throne anymore and it'll go
back to splitting each of the kingdoms
up the way it was before Aegon's
conquest which I don't totally agree
with but I do think that Daenerys will
wind up winning like team Daenerys
because she has John Snow and the people
of the north they're destined to defeat
Cersei and even if they decide in the
wake of the war to shift to a more
democratic system of rule it'll still
largely be the same major houses even
though House Lannister is effectively
devastated you still have Tyrion I think
the idea though is is that whoever is
left to rule if Daenerys survives or if
she dies in childbirth and someone's
left to be regent for her like Tyrion
until their child is old enough to rule
then it'll just be a little less
autocratic like they'll do their best to
maintain a monarchy but one that listens
to people tries to work with the other
Lords a little bit more than say sir she
is right now or say the Mad King did
during his reign one of the bad things I
think that's happened the last couple of
seasons is that the way they've written
tyrion hasn't been quite as good so
people haven't been focusing on him as
an important character like last season
it was mostly about Jon Snow meeting
Daenerys them forming that alliance
watching Cersei finally sit on the Iron
Throne and start grasping at straws as
her power base started to erode around
her once we get winds of winter and we
start getting teasers and trailers for
season 8 there'll be a lot more Tyrion
stuff to talk about there's just so much
there that they never really get to on
the TV show he's such a dynamic
character Tyrion just talks and his
tongue is always getting him into
trouble so just post all your Tyrion
finale theories in the comments below
Fire and Ice congratulations you're the
latest giveaway winner for my last big
video please email me on the about page
my channel so I can get your details
click here to watch Peter Dinklage talk
about the final season and click here
for my golden company video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight